[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend na also die sondierungen
zwischen rot gelb und grün gingen
schneller wenn auch am ende länger als
gedacht schlussspurt durch die nacht bis
morgens um fünf was dann aber offenbar
stimmte wahren geist und atmosphäre der
ersten gemeinsamen woche den eindruck
machten die müden aber harmonischen
unterhändler und händlerinnen da muss
natürlich jeder hinweis miesepetrig
wirken dass die absätze über
finanzierungen in höhe von 100
milliarden euro zur wahrung des
einklangs dann ziemlich wolkig gehalten
wurden das ist aber so die konflikte
kommen also noch man wird sehen wie lang
der zauber des anfangs hält den thomas
reichert beobachtet hat
als sie heute mittag immer noch mehr
mikrofone aufstellen wird eines klar
wenn so viele plötzlich gesprächig
werden ist das kein schlechtes zeichen
für die ampel sondierungen am morgen
noch kalt wir sagen nichts nicht die spd
nicht die fdp und auch nicht die grünen
selbst einer wie fdp-vize kubicki sagt
fast nichts
aber dann um kurz vor eins wird hektisch
ein papier verteilt und nun wollen alle
was sagen alle fünf parteivorsitzenden
plus kanzlerkandidat um genau zu sein
tatsächlich ist es gelungen wir haben
uns auf ein papier einen text zur
sondierung verständigt der jetzt die
grundlage für die entscheidungen in den
parteien bilden kann die ganze nacht bis
in den frühen morgen haben sie im
geheimen noch über eben jenes papier
verhandelt manchem sieht man das auch an
an der seitenlinie aus derweil das neue
team ampel eng beieinander es wäre das
schon immer so erleichtert irgendwie
und christian lindner hat sich für die
gelegenheit ein paar extra große worte
notiert
wir sind überzeugt nach diesen
gesprächen
dass
es lange zeit
keine vergleichbare chance gegeben hat
gesellschaft wirtschaft und staat zu
modernisieren
dafür kann jeder der drei ein paar
punkte machen die spd bekommt zwölf euro
mindestlohn und es gibt keine
rentenkürzung die fdp erreicht dies es
gibt kein tempolimit keine
steuererhöhungen auch die schuldenbremse
bleibt
damit wir nicht nur auf den kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner weiter politik in
diesem land machen sondern in einer
fortschritts koalition auch für eine
wirkliche erneuerung sorgen war es
wichtig dass bei drei unterschiedlichen
parteien ein verständnis da ist dass
jeder auch mal was gibt und umgekehrt
bekommt die grünen viel ihre klima
forderungen die ampel verspricht
deutschland auf den 1,5 grad fahrt zu
bringen den kohleausstieg vorzuziehen
wenn möglich auf 2.030 und solarenergie
für alle geeigneten dachflächen so weit
so konkret nur bei der finanzierung ist
noch viel offen mit dem was wir jetzt
hier miteinander vereinbart haben
besteht der fiskalische spielraum den
wir brauchen für das was notwendig ist
das betrifft die investitionen die wir
brauchen und selbstverständlich glauben
wir dass wir in diesem rahmen das alles
realisieren können am nachmittag machte
der spd vorstand den weg frei für
offizielle koalitionsverhandlungen am
sonntag sollen die grünen folgender
montag die fdp jetzt ist es schließlich
raus jetzt haben sie geredet
guten abend herr beck guten abend herr
kleber sie machten da auf dieser bühne
alle so einen glücklichen und
harmonischen eindruck ist dass denn auch
mit genügend sachlichen argumenten
unterfüttert na ja auch ein bisschen
über müde und glaube ich und dann dann
ist man so aber in der tat glaube ich
haben wir heute etwas gutes gemacht also
das waren anstrengende wochen und auch
heute in kürze eine kurze nacht aber das
papier kann sich sehen lassen für die
dann doch kurze phase die wir sondiert
haben sind wir durchaus stolz drauf
vielleicht ist es auch deswegen so
schnell gegangen am ende weil sie viele
sachen raus gelassen haben wenn man sich
das papier anschaut da ist sehr viel
poesie album da ist innovatives bündnis
verlässliche regierung vertrauen respekt
schnelle verwaltung agiler digitaler und
so und dann findet man die die
spezifischen dinge auch da ist ein
generelles tempolimit wird es nicht
geben der mindestlohn das war der große
wunsch der spd wird einmal auf 12 euro
pro stunde erhöht und es wird
solardächer zur pflicht geben
und dann verschwindet so ein bisschen
das konkrete was habe ich da verpasst da
wird viel im folgenden wird viel erzählt
was man alles anstrebt und will und 1,5
grad strebt man an früheren
kohleausstieg strebt man an die einen
leute klickten wie zb bei tempolimit und
keine steuererhöhungen was konkretes und
die andere seite kriegt relativ häufig
ist das habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden
sie haben konkrete dinge auf gezielt
also ich glaube es ist ein sehr
konkreter text ich vermisse das konkrete
zum beispiel zum thema finanzierung da
steht wir werden keine steuern erhöhen
ein riesen wunsch der fdp die überhaupt
ziemlich glücklich sein kann und bei den
zielen jetzt wie früherer kohleausstieg
oder stärkere solarenergie und
redet ist die rede von anstreben und
bemühen und wollen aber nicht von machen
die klimaschutzziele sind und auch die
maßnahmen sind sehr konkret beschrieben
und zwar nicht nur beim energie ausbau
also solarpflicht ist das stichwort
genannt und zwei prozent der
bundesdeutschen fläche sollte
windkraftanlagen freigeschalten
freigehalten werden oder bebaut werden
daraus ergibt sich dann die möglichkeit
die kohlekraftwerke vor abzuschalten das
ist sehr konkret und die finanzen sind
besser unterliegt in den gesprächen als
es das papier wieder gibt die sätze sind
spartanisch das gebe ich zu aber wir
haben uns sehr viele gedanken dazu
gemacht wie diese setze dann in den
koalitionsverhandlungen mit konkreten
möglichkeiten unterfüttert werden da
gebe ich ihnen einen halben punkt da
haben sie recht aber das heißt nicht
dass wir dort waage geblieben sind in
den gesprächen sondern wir werden dann
in drei vier wochen sehen dass das sehr
genau mit maßnahmen zu hinterlegen ist
ich habe beim lesen des papiers das
verständnis bekommen dass vor allen
dingen die fdp ihre position doch
erstaunlich konkret hat festnageln
können es gibt kein tempolimit es gibt
keine steuererhöhungen es bleibt
weiterhin beim dualen system von
gesetzlicher und privater
krankenversicherung
diese kernforderungen sind bereits jetzt
nach dem vorspiel sozusagen im sinne der
fdp geregelt und für sie muss auch
einiges kommen die fdp hat auch ihre
punkte und ich glaube die
sozialdemokratie hat jedenfalls ihre
punkte und wir haben auch unsere punkte
wir haben eben schon über den
klimaschutz geredet sofern wir das als
unsere punkte überhaupt reklamieren
wollen denn das ist ja beschlossene
gesetzeslage wandel deutschland
klimaneutral werden soll nur sind jetzt
eben die maßnahmen nach gezogen worden
es gibt gute sätze zur verträglichkeit
von landwirtschaft und natur wir sind im
gesellschaftlichen bereich also
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
staatsbürgerschaftsrecht informieren
doppelte staatsbürgerschaft anerkennung
von von von bbq also vielfältigen
lebensformen deutlich vorangekommen also
wir denken nicht danach wirklich dir
welche punkte wäre würde man es tun
würde ich behaupten das ist ungefähr für
alle gleich gut ausgeht jedenfalls ist
dass der anspruch des papieres welche
rolle spielt bei der finanzierung der
trick 22 der trick 22 meint das nächste
jahr wo wegen der pandemie die
schuldenbremse noch aufgeweicht ist der
verdacht steht im raum dass man dann
nächstes jahr einen großen haufen
schulden macht wie man dann in den
folgejahren abrufen kann und damit hat
man sozusagen die schuldenbremse
gleichzeitig verletzt und eingehalten
das hat bisher keine rolle in den
gesprächen gespielt wir haben in der tat
möglichkeiten gesucht wie wir unter
einhaltung der schuldenbremse
die notwendigen und ich betonen ist sind
ja notwendige investition in die zukunft
technologien in den klimaschutz aber
auch in die digitale infrastruktur in
forschung und entwicklung deutlich heben
können deutschland hat immer
unterdurchschnittlich investiert in den
letzten jahren sind also auch unterhalb
des europäischen durchschnitts das
reiche deutschland
das muss man sich mal klar machen wir
hatten eine extreme wachstumsschwäche in
deutschland vor der korona pandemie
insofern haben wir möglichkeiten gesucht
und auch gefunden wie wir innerhalb der
schuldenbremse die
investitionstätigkeiten der öffentlichen
hand des staates hebeln können die
möglichkeit im nächsten jahr nochmal
deutlich mehr schulden aufzunehmen
gehören nicht dazu mit einem mit einer
ausnahme dass die fdp auf ein neues
rentensystem gedrungen hat und dafür
werden 10 milliarden im nächsten jahr
kreditfinanziert bereitgestellt also
insofern hat die fdp die sagt ja immer
schulden schaffen keine zukunft bei der
rente hat sie da offensichtlich eine
andere meinung und dieser meinung sind
wir dann testhalber gefolgt testhalber
gefolgt was ist ihr gefühl nach diesem
ersten kapitel ist überhaupt in ihrem
kopf noch die chance dass das scheitern
könnte und dass man die cdu und csu für
eine vielleicht dann doch jamaika option
noch brauchen könnte also das ist ja
erst einmal einen vorschlag an die
gremien wir haben am sonntag ein
parteitag die fdp wird ebenfalls ihre
gremien befassen und die spd auch also
wir sind ja sozusagen formal gesehen
noch nicht wirklich weit und dann kommen
erst die koalitionsgespräche aber sie
haben recht die letzten 14 tage haben
eine dynamik entfacht und auch uns
gegenseitig bewiesen dass wir
vertrauensvoll und verlässlich
miteinander umgehen können dass ein
scheitern jetzt wirklich eine
überraschung wäre ich gehe davon nicht
mehr aus aber das liegt auch daran dass
wir gesehen haben dass wir wie wir und
dass wir konflikte lösen können und
konflikte haben wir noch einige eine
erste einschätzung nach dem vorspiel wie
sie vorhin sagten die anderen partner
werden in unserem programm noch zur rede
kommen dankeschön er habe keine schönen
abend wünsche ich auch
in dem sinne es im heute journal update
die juso vorsitzende jessica rosenthal
zu gast und das gespräch mit robert
habeck haben wir vor stunden geführt als
der himmel über hamburg fast noch ein
bisschen hell war derweil hält die junge
union in münster mitten in der
schwersten krise der cdu
ihre jahresversammlung ab die otto hat
knapp 100000 mitglieder das macht sie
zur größten politischen
jugendorganisation gibt aber keine
garantie dass die sich durchsetzen kann
im gegenteil sie hatte märz gewollt und
bekam laschet dann hat sie selber
gewollt und bekam laschet dann hat sie
eine konservative wende erhofft und
bekam eine wahlniederlage im aktuellen
politbarometer sinkt die union bei uns
zum ersten mal überhaupt unter 20
prozent auf 19 nun sucht nicht nur die
junge sondern die ganze union eine neue
führung und einen neuen weg der redner
aus der alten union war heute zum
auftakt friedrich merz
große worte sind schnell gesagt
familientreffen neu anfangen dass das
hier nichts von einem familientreffen
hat hat silvan kuban eigentlich selbst
zugegeben zwei stunden vorher
pressekonferenz der j chef schwärmt von
armin laschet und gibt markus söder
ordentlich einen mit
hoch anzurechnen dass er obwohl er klar
gesagt hat dass er jetzt den übergang
organisiert trotzdem auch zur jungen
union kommt es ist ja auch hinlänglich
bekannt dass die junge union sich vorher
für markus söder mehrheitlich
ausgesprochen hat und deswegen zeigt es
dass armin laschet ihr stark im starken
charakter zeigt und sich der diskussion
stellt auch mit den delegierten und
gästen diskutieren wird und ich hätte
mir das gleiche von markus söder auch
gewünscht was übersetzt heißt markus
söder hat in den augen der jungen union
keinen charakter der csu-chef hatte als
gastredner erst zu und dann kurzfristig
abgesagt der einstige liebling der
jungen union bekommt in abwesenheit sein
fett weg aber nicht nur er wer im
wahlkampf so auftritt wie armin laschet
er sollte nach der wahl nicht direkt in
anspruch erheben kanzler zu werden
sondern vor allen dingen verantwortung
für das ergebnis zu übernehmen
armin laschet wird morgen herr kommen
heute abend kommt erstmal friedrich merz
zweimal wollte er schon parteichef
werden
will you love me or gen spielt der
parteitag wird märz ein drittes mal chef
werden wollen die union ist mit diesem
wahlergebnis
ein
insolvenzgefährdete schwerer politischer
sanierungsfall geworden es kommt
natürlich darauf an wer die union in
zukunft führt aber da geht es nicht um
eine person sondern da geht es um eine
führungsmannschaft und da ist auch nicht
jedes wort was da gesagt wird gleich
eins zu eins richtig ja natürlich junge
besen kehren gut
aber die alte bürste kennt die ecken
doch die selbsternannte bürste kommt
heute nicht so an wie in früheren zeiten
früher stand nach einer kantigen märz
rede der saal heute bleiben manche
landesverbände auf ihren plätzen sitzen
auch verbal
motivierten friedrich merz gehört und
ich wünsche mir dass auch weiter in der
partei fahrt war wasser in der fraktion
verantwortung übernimmt wir brauchen
menschen wie ihn er zeigt klare kante
und dann schauen wir was ich glaube
friedrich schmerz ist in der
vergangenheit auch viel für die partei
inhaltlich getan aber ich bin ein großer
fan verriet cannon lienemann oder
ja auch sparen die junge union plädiert
für eine mitgliederbefragung um einen
neuen chef oder eine neue chefin zu
finden das wäre tatsächlich mal was
neues und
die nachrichten müssen mit wohl
politisch gefärbten verbrechen begehen
in großbritannien ist ein abgeordneter
der konservativen regierungspartei bei
einer messerattacke getötet worden der
tory abgeordnete david haines war
während einer bürgersprechstunde
angegriffen worden noch gibt es keine
informationen über mögliche hintergründe
der tat die polizei geht von einem
einzeltäter aus und nahm den
mutmaßlichen angreifer einen 25 jahre
alten mann fest es galt als
erzkonservativer praxis befürworter
politiker aus allen lagern reagierten
entsetzt auf die bluttat
nach der gewalttat im norwegischen
kongsberg konzentrieren sich die
ermittlungen auf den psychischen zustand
des täters ein terroristisches motiv
wird mittlerweile für unwahrscheinlich
gehalten
rechtspsychiater sollen dem fall nun
untersuchen
der 37 jährige zum islam konvertierte
däne hatte vorgestern mit pfeil und
bogen vier frauen und einen mann getötet
im süden afghanistans sind bei einer
serie von anschlägen auf eine
schiitische moschee mindestens 32
menschen getötet worden noch hat sich
niemand zu den anschlägen während des
freitagsgebetes bekannt die taliban
verurteilten die gewalt vor einer woche
hatte die sunnitische terror miliz es
einen anschlag für sich reklamiert dabei
waren ebenfalls in einer schiitischen
moschee mehr als 40 menschen getötet
worden
im tarifstreit des deutschen baugewerbes
ist man in der dritten schlichtungsrunde
zu einer einigung gekommen vor allem die
neue entschädigung für die anfahrten zu
den baustellen wird von der ig bau als
tarifpolitischer meilenstein gefeiert
dazu erhalten die 890.000 beschäftigten
mehr geld in drei stufen steigt das
abkommen hat das einkommen im westen in
den nächsten 33 monaten um insgesamt 62
prozent im osten um 8,5 prozent außerdem
gibt es eine corona prämie sowie eine
einmalzahlung
eines der letzten symbol projekte der
linksautonomen szene in berlin ist
geräumt worden das wagen kämpfe auf dem
kirchplatz in berlin-mitte fast 2000
polizisten waren im einsatz auch mit
kettensägen und räumpanzer die etwa 40
bewohner des camps weigerten sich den
gerichtlichen räumungsbeschluss zu
folgen und leisteten gegenwehr mehr als
20 menschen wurden festgenommen
am früheren mauerstreifen in ost-berlin
hatten linke aktivisten seit den 1990 er
jahren ein bauwagen camp gebaut
italien ist seit dem schrecken von
bergamo weit gekommen im ringen mit der
korona pandemie mehr als 80 prozent der
über zwölfjährigen sind vollständig
geimpft und nun greift die regierung
draghi zu einer europaweit einmaligen
drastischen maßnahme sie will diese
pandemie ist endgültig hinter sich
bringen die meisten finden das gut
manche nicht und die könnten der
regierung noch große probleme machen
annette hilsenbeck berichtet ausruhen
die italienerinnen und italiener
unterhalten sich gerne und viel beim
kaffee morgens vor allem aber beim
aperitivo nach feierabend
traditionell wird da übers essen
gefachsimpelt doch das italienische
lieblingsthema wird zurzeit oft
verdrängt von einem anderen dem green
pass türöffner für museen restaurants
oder fernzüge politisches steuerelement
der italienischen regierung sie tun gut
daran den ball zu fordern absolut wenn
wir jetzt daraus kommen ist das wegen
der maßnahmen die ergriffen haben ohne
das was machen wir gehen wird ein zurück
wo wir waren
ich denke dass jeder frei ist zu denken
was er will aber wenn es um die
gesundheit aller geht sollte man sich
ein bisschen zurücknehmen und anpassen
es gibt situationen da muss man im
großen denken eher an die gemeinschaft
als anders individuen meiner meinung
nach ist das richtig ich habe es gemacht
meine kinder sind klein sie sind geimpft
ich habe ein großes opfer meines
gewissens gebracht
seit heute ist der green pass per gesetz
allgegenwärtig auch in der arbeitswelt
der arbeitgeber ist verpflichtet seine
belegschaft zu kontrollieren nur wenn
den grünen pass vorweisen kann geimpft
genesen oder frisch getestet es darf an
den arbeitsplatz wer ihn nicht hat wird
freigestellt und zwar ohne bezahlung
der staatliche druck jetzt könnte noch
einige ungeimpfte mürbe machen denn die
freiheit sich nicht impfen zu lassen
erkauft man sich mühsam per corona
schnelltest heute morgen hieß das
schlange stehen und 15 euro pro test
zahlen
gerade viele erst impfungen durchgeführt
die menschen lassen sich weiterhin
impfen wir haben jetzt mehr als 80
prozent der bevölkerung über zwölf jahre
die vollständig geimpft sind
doch gegen den greenpeace gibt es
heftige proteste auch heute im hafen von
triest von denen die sich als minderheit
diskriminiert und nicht gehört fühlen
ich fühle mich als ob ich eines der
obersten menschenrechte beraubt werde
arbeiten
am vergangenen wochenende nutzten
rechtsextreme und neofaschisten die von
protesten aufgeheizte stimmung in rom
gewalt und aggression gegen einen staat
eben die meisten den italien jedenfalls
in sachen green pass zu stimmen denn
keiner will mehr erleben dass man sich
nicht zum aperitivo treffen kann alles
schließen muss wie vor einem jahr als
die zahl der infizierten wieder
hochschnellte alles schloss eine
schreckensvisionen größer als die des
green pass
die eeg umlage zur finanzierung des
ausbaus erneuerbarer energien wird im
nächsten jahr deutlich sinken der noch
amtierende wirtschaftsminister altmaier
bezeichnet das als gute nachricht für
verbraucher und wirtschaft und fordert
zugleich die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
denn sina mainitz diese entscheidung der
netzbetreiber führt nicht dazu dass die
hohen strompreise sinken ja genau das
ist genau der knackpunkt mit dieser
umlage aus dem erneuerbare energien
gesetz zahlt jeder stromkunde die
energiewende mit nun sinkt diese umlage
auf den niedrigsten stand seit zehn
jahren von sechseinhalb cent auf rund
3,7 cent pro kilowattstunde eigentlich
sollten verbraucher damit künftig
entlastet werden doch die
beschaffungskosten für strom sind auf
rekordhoch und deutschland ist bei den
strompreisen weltweit führend knapp 32
cent kostet derzeit eine kilowattstunde
die umlage beträgt ab januar 37 2 cent
sie fällt auch deshalb so gering aus
weil der bund 3,25 milliarden euro
zuschießt neben der eeg-umlage gibt es
noch andere komponenten die den
strompreis ausmachen nämlich die
netzentgelte diese sollen kommendes jahr
steigen ebenso wie vermutlich auch die 1
preise am strommarkt anziehen werden die
eeg-umlage sinkt aber damit werden nur
die höheren einkaufspreise an der
strombörse ausgeglichen um private
haushalte und betriebe tatsächlich zu
entlasten spricht die politik deshalb
auch immer wieder von der abschaffung
der eeg umlage darum wird es wohl auch
in den koalitionsverhandlungen zwischen
spd grünen und fdp gehen geradezu
energiegeladen beendet der dax diese
börsenwoche er ist den dritten tag in
folge im plus heute ein schlussstand von
15.500 87 punkten passend zum thema zu
den spitzenreiter im dax gehören die
energieversorger vielen dank seiner nach
frankfurt
hausbesitzer und wohnungseigentümer
dürfen ihre maroden gebäude nicht
verfallen lassen sondern müssen sie
sanieren der bundesgerichtshof hat in
einem urteil gibt pflicht zur sanierung
betont und nur wenige ausnahmen
zugelassen wie zb bei bränden oder
überflutungen auch wenn die
sanierungskosten hoch sein so der bgh
dürften gebäude nicht dem verfall
preisgegeben werden
in der fußball-bundesliga hat der achte
spieltag begonnen mit der partie
hoffenheim gegen erster fc köln das
spiegeln gerade eben zu ende gewonnen
hat klar hoffenheim 15 uhr
auf der kanaren insel la palma leiden
die menschen nun seit vier wochen unter
dem aktiven vulkan heute bebte
zusätzlich erneut die erde auf la palma
zum zweiten mal binnen kurzem die beben
der stärke 4,5 sind die heftigsten seit
beginn des ausbruchs tausende anwohner
mussten bereits ihre häuser verlassen
wissenschaftler beschreiben die
lavaströme als so wörtlich echten lava
tsunami der vulkan werfe meeres
sedimente aus die auf die entstehung la
palmas vor zwei millionen jahren
zurückgingen
einer der frühen großen stars des
erklärenden fakten basierten fernsehens
wäre heute 100 jahre alt geworden
professor heuser von dietfurt hat in den
70er und 80er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts millionen menschen das
weltall und die welt erklärt er wagte es
klar und deutlich wahrheit zu sagen auch
wenn die unerhört war
die wüstengebiete werden sich ausdehnen
werden wandern die polkappen werden
abschmelzen der wasserspiegel wird
ansteigen all das wirkt jetzt noch wie
ein
szenario aus einem science fiction roman
von einer wüsten fantasie ausgedacht
unsere kinder spätestens unsere
enkelkinder werden erfahren dass das
meer ist und inzwischen haben die es
erfahren unfassbare 43 jahre alt ist
dieser ton die welt wäre heute unter
viel weniger druck hätten nicht so viele
so lange seit damals auf dem schlauch
gestanden und das geht mit zahlen weiter
mit politischen zahlen von matthias
fornoff wir wünschen ein schönes
wochenende bis morgen
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer bei einer verkehrsampel
leuchtet das gelb immer nur kurz rot und
grün regeln wo es langgeht eine ampel in
der politik funktioniert anders in ihr
möchte jede partei so hell wie möglich
leuchten und stets erkennbar sein im
ersten schritt beim sondieren schien das
zu gelingen zumindest rang ein streit
nach außen wohl das deutlichste zeichen
dafür dass spd grüne und fdp es ernst
meinen mit dem dreierbündnis und das
gefällt offensichtlich den befragten
62 prozent finden dieses
koalitionsmodell gut 19 prozent schlecht
die realistischen alternativen ein
jamaika bündnis unter führung der union
oder die spd geführte große koalition
lehnen deutliche mehrheiten ab
dass die ampel tatsächlich zustande
kommt glauben die allermeisten 88
prozent doch noch ist nichts entschieden
die themen längst nicht aus vor allem
bei den finanzen könnte es im detail
schwierig werden investitionen soll es
so heißt es heute nur im rahmen der
schuldenbremse geben wie stehen die
befragten dazu wenn der staat jetzt
zusätzlich schulden aufnehmen würde
fänden dass 41 prozent gut 53 prozent
aber schlecht aufgeschlüsselt nach
parteianhängern findet sich die höchste
zustimmung bei den anhängern der grünen
und linken die der spd zeigen sich eher
unentschieden anhänger von union fdp und
afd lehnen zusätzliche schulden jeweils
zu etwa drei vierteln ab
auch bei der frage nach mehr steuern für
hohe einkommen klassen die
parteiprogramme von spd und grünen
einerseits und der fdp andererseits weit
auseinander trotzdem mit olaf scholz die
ampel noch vor weihnachten auf die beine
stellen mit sich selbst als kanzler
wenn olaf scholz kanzler wird finden
dass drei viertel der deutschen eher gut
17 prozent schlecht ein starker rückhalt
der sich mehr oder weniger quer durch
die parteianhänger zieht selbst die
anhänger der union finden scholz
mehrheitlich gut als kanzler
vor drei wochen war bundestagswahl wenn
an diesem sonntag schon wieder gewählt
würde käme die spd auf 28 prozent und
verändert im vergleich zur umfrage vor
zwei wochen
cdu/csu 19 prozent neuer negativrekord
grüne 17 +1 fdp 13 afd 11 plus 1 und
linke 5 prozent
zum ersten mal überhaupt rutschen
cdu/csu unter 20 prozent eine
momentaufnahme
unter dem eindruck des historisch
schwachen wahlergebnisses und der
ungeklärten führungsfrage knapp zwei
drittel glauben allerdings dass die
schwäche der union länger anhalten wird
schauen wir auf unsere top ten also die
bewertung der zehn wichtigsten politiker
nach sympathie und leistung auf der
skala von +5 bis -5 ist armin laschet
weiter schlusslicht minus 1,3 leicht
verschlechtert vorletzter friedrich merz
minus 0,4 schlechter jens spahn minus
0,1 etwas verschlechtert annalena
baerbock 0,4 davor markus söder 0,5 sehr
deutliche verluste auf der 5 christian
lindner 0,9 etwas schlechter robert
habeck 1,7 etwas verbessert auf dem
dritten platz wieder dabei manuela
schwesig 1,8 zweiter olaf scholz 2,0
verschlechtert und ganz vorn angela
merkel weiter mit 2,3
die tage werden kürzer und damit die
sorgen wieder größer wie wir durch
diesen corona winter kommen werden 40
prozent halten ihre gesundheit durch das
virus für gefährdet etwas mehr als vor
zwei wochen welche regeln und maßnahmen
sind jetzt angezeigt um die pandemie im
griff zu behalten
vor allem über den umgang mit
ungeimpften wird debattiert
das deutschlandweit die 2g regel im
freizeit und kulturbereich eingeführt
wird die ausschließlich geimpften und
genesenen zutritt erlaubt finden 62
prozent gut die geringste zustimmung bei
den anhängern der fdp und der linken
seit dieser woche müssen bürger einen
corona schnelltest selbst bezahlen das
gilt für alle die sich impfen lassen
könnten
71 prozent finden dass auch richtig 28
prozent meinen dass das nicht richtig
ist
gut jeder zweite glaubt dass es im
winter bei uns zu einer neuen
infektionswelle kommen wird fast genau
so viele rechnen nicht damit viel
unsicherheit also wohl auch weil niemand
so genau weiß wie sich die pandemie
weiter entwickelt das war unser bericht
über die stimmung im land die grafiken
und alle informationen zu unseren
umfragen finden sie wie immer im zdf
text ab seite 165 in unserer zdf heute
app und auf zdf heute.de wie die
repräsentativen umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards
sie unter politbarometer
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
29 oktober und nach dem wetter geht's
hier weiter mit der heute-show ihnen
noch einen schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das unwetter tief über dem
östlichen mittelmeer wird sich jetzt am
wochenende über der türkei auflösen und
bei uns nimmt dieses tief gerold seine
kaltfront mit und für uns wird am
wochenende das hoch philine interessant
das bringt ruhiges herbstwetter unter
nach wird es deutlich milder heute nacht
gibt es also nur noch ganz wenig regen
hier am main sonst ist es mal mehr mal
weniger stark bewölkt es bildet sich
auch mal nebel und dann wird es kalt da
sinken die temperaturen auf plus fünf
bis minus 1 grad und örtlich droht
wieder bodenfrost bilder bleibt die
nacht an den küsten von nord- und ostsee
mit 10 bis 7 grad und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen meist um 13 grad
etwas kühler ist es in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen milder dagegen am
oberrhein mit 16 grad und nach nebel und
dunst am morgen scheint in
süddeutschland doch häufig die sonne
richtung norden sind die wolken dichter
und direkt an der see kann es auch mal
ein bisschen tröpfeln und an diesem
wetter ändert sich auch am sonntag wenig
aber in der neuen woche da wird es
erstmal deutlich milder dann aber auch
regnerischer und windiger besonders am
mittwoch und wie das genau aussieht
möchte ich ihnen an zwei beispielen
zeigen am kap arkona auf rügen da
steigen die temperaturen mitte der
nächsten woche in richtung 15 grad es
ist eher wechselhaft und in freiburg im
breisgau geht sogar noch mal bis 22 grad
rauf das sind doch mal ausrichten
schönes wochenende